je sais ce que vous vous dites comment
diable à vendeurs de machines ami jake
de 52 ans sur le retour peut-il bâtir
l'empiré du fast food à partir de rien
voir 1600 restaurant et un revenu annuel
qui avoisine la modique somme de 700
millions de dollars
ça tient en un mot la persévérance
winx cassel bonjour cellule est alors
comment ça se passe mais tonnerre les
clients sont très enthousiastes
on a une commande simics l'adresse
acquis mcdonald's voulait faire le tour
on voulait quelque chose de différent
mais c'est là que mon petit frère a eu
l'une de ses meilleures idées déco
membres et en 30 secondes au lieu de 30
minutes une originale on n'a jamais vu
ça c'est révolutionnaire exactement ça
c'est révolutionnaire c'est quoi ça les
arches d'oreilles 5000 restaurants leur
faut des mcdonald's partout sa franchise
à monsieur franchisés franchise est
franchie
mcdonald's pourrait bien être la
nouvelle église américaine et j'ai pas
ouverte que le dimanche comment plutôt
avoir épuisé tous capita j'ai appris une
hypothèque sur notre maison
on pourrait tout perdre je veux en
négocier mon contrat merdique je ne peux
pas vous voulez pas vrai quoi non bon
dieu que je vous conseille dorénavant
c'est d'acheter des parcelles de terrain
sur lequel se vendent burger effet vous
n'êtes pas dans les hamburgers
vous êtes dans l'immobilier et un petit
corporation c'est une société
indépendante qui dépasse les limites de
vos attributions il ya un loup dans la
bergerie on lui a ouvert la porte
quand est ce que tu vas tu arrêter sans
doute jamais vous allez arrêter sur le
champ
je ne vais plus accepter vos directives
vous avez signé un contrat un contrat
c'est comme un coeur c'est fait pour
être brisé
le business c'est la guerre n'en faire
des agneaux le paradis des requins je
vais conquérir l'avenir je veux gagner
le frère son mot associé à nu les
contrats quelles que soient les
conditions
ce nom extraordinaire mcdonald's il
fallait que j'aie non vous ne vais pas
vous en êtes bien sûr